[Music]
all right so I'm Christopher Hine we're
talking this week about how to eat which
literally translates as belly power but
it's kind of just a blanket term that we
use for making good alignments and
proper ways to use the body that seemed
very strong sometimes deceptively strong
and that's why sometimes these
techniques can be used to deceive people
to think you got special powers but in
truth they're just principles that we
can use in lots of different ways one of
the principles that I think is really
impressive is connecting to the force
structure and so this is my own term for
it I don't know a fancy Japanese word or
any other kind of word for this but
basically the idea is when something
trying to push you over if you can
connect to it meaning you can physically
touch it in some way then it's harder
for that force to drive you over and you
know in essence it's kind of like you're
riding along with them right so like if
you think about a horse you know if you
try to resist the horse pushing you
that's really hard but if you grab the
horse's neck when they try to push you
then you would just move along with the
horse and that's kind of this idea of
connecting to force structure so I'm
gonna call Sasha in here and we're gonna
talk about this concept a little more
okay so we're going to talk about
connecting force structure here I'm
gonna just push it over right now so I
want you to resist nice and square like
that since I she's not gonna have an
advantage by pushing the book actually
since in square and I'm gonna try to
push her over all right so I weigh 200
pounds Sasha weighs 100 pounds not very
difficult to do
now we're gonna have Sasha connect to
the structure that's pushing her so as I
put my hands on Sasha's shoulders Sasha
is going to touch underneath my elbows
like this and then they begin to drive
into Sasha she's going to connect
I mean when I'd read pretty Socktober
I'm actually kind of trying to push
myself over like this two things are
actually happening in one one is that
her sinner is actually being driven a
little lower than my Center as she
connects and pushes into my elbows like
this what's happening is she's kind of
lifting me up a little bit while she's
pushing herself down at the same time
the other thing is she's distracting the
force that I'm putting into her while
I'm trying to push it or the forces
being strapped up so I can really start
to push into her here and it's much
harder for me because she's connected to
the structure of my body another ways to
show this and his common in greco-roman
wrestling is a great bunt if I were to
get here behind Sasha like this and go
to pick Sasha up it's relatively easy
now when I do it this time it's gonna be
much more difficult for me what's what
happens okay so I'm not just acting
that's a really difficult thing to do
now the reason is because what Sasha did
was she's wrapping her leg around and
hooking behind my leg like this and so
when I go to lift her she's connected to
the structure that's provided force so
as they go to lift up so I'm using our
legs treat that her core against me and
she's got way harder to lift up another
really sneaky way to do this it's pretty
pretty deceptive if I were to bring up
Sasha like this if I get ready to eat
sausage shoulders and I pick her up not
too hard Sasha goes underneath my elbows
again this time they go to pick her up
it's insanely insanely difficult now the
reason it's so hard is a few things
right one thing is sauce is for SUNY to
have a long lever if I even get in like
this notice how close my hands are to
the fulcrum of my shoulders when Sasha
puts her hands under my elbows it's hard
for me to get my hands in that close so
she's giving me a long lever second
thing she's doing she's connecting to
the structure that's providing force so
she's actually connecting herself to me
so as I'm trying to let up I'm actually
kind of
it's myself since distracting a ton of
the force that's going into her back
into me so by connecting to the
structure like this we can do a whole
lot of impressive things one of the very
famous impressive things that was done
with this
but if Sorceress's isn't for me and now
we know through alignment that it's
possible for Sasha to hold back a fair
amount of force but still even even with
good alignment because I'm so much
stronger I could probably manage to
overcome her eventually hug she connects
to my elbows here when I go to push her
over she just got a ton stronger really
push and she's able to resist me and the
reason is because she's connecting to
the structure that's putting force into
her any time we do that can get a big
gain in power connecting the core
structure